football pod in america tony dungy is
here so is rodney harrison mike florio
i'm lee mchugh coming at you from my
attic as i continue isolation and follow
the protocol
don't worry worry rodney i'm fine thanks
for asking
doing okay i'm lonely i miss you guys
and i can't wait to get back on the show
but you guys
guys are all doing well tony great job
in green bed
well thank you liam i missed you guys
too it was great doing a game and great
being in all that history but i missed
my guys in the studio
hey liam liam liam liam the first time
i'm in studio on a sunday i come up i'm
scared to death initially to fly i get
on the plane i'm comfortable and then
i'm i'm excited to see my guys and then
i don't see you liam i was so
disappointed my man
i know i'm i'm running out of excuses
liam all i have to add is this
i'm glad it's your attic and not where
you ordinarily live because it looks
like you're about to be interrogated
under suspicion of some sort of capital
crime
right like the cops are about to walk in
and really really put it to you that's
that's what where were you on the night
of the 18th yeah
it has that feel right now it definitely
does
rodney i i'm i'm out of excuses for
dodging you at this point uh it's empty
we will connect this will happen before
the end of the regular season i promise
and listen let's talk about that because
we're slowly approaching it right the
end of the regular season just about a
month away if we stay to schedule that's
the plan right now in the nfl there is
no bubble but we have bubble teams and
we're going to talk about five of them
today we're going to decide whether
these are teams that are going to be
legitimate threats come play off time
whether these are teams perhaps they
just make the playoffs and then make no
noise once they get in or perhaps you
think that these are teams that are just
going to miss out
all together let's begin with the
raiders because the last time i worked
it was just about two weeks ago i was in
las vegas jason witten nearly
what pulled the rabbit out of his head
and caught that touchdown pass they were
one minute 43 seconds away from beating
the chiefs at that point they would have
gone to seven and three instead patrick
mahomes he's a magician they lose that
game they get crushed by atlanta so now
they are six and five tony what should
we make of this team from vegas
well i i think they're just an
inconsistent team like a lot of teams in
the nfl right now they haven't hit their
stride we see some great play uh i was
shocked that they could not run the ball
on the atlanta falcons that's the one
thing
they seem to hang their head on josh
jacobs ponding that football week in and
week out and then they go and i think
they had six yards rushing in in the
first half so uh the inconsistency i
don't think defensively they're good
enough uh to carry the team um they're
just they're an up and down football
team right now
and i'm looking at henry ruggs he was
supposed to come in and provide him with
dynamic plays down the field and he's
been inconsistent so when i look at this
offense i think it starts on the
offensive side of the ball especially up
front
mike gloria
well look i i i still don't know what
the hell happened i don't think the
raiders know what the hell happened they
walked into a buzz saw and i think what
happened was plain and simple they
couldn't recover from nearly beating the
chiefs a week before and and so you get
it in your head that we had him right
where we wanted him and we couldn't get
it done and oh it's just atlanta and
we're going to go to atlanta and all we
have to do is show up and win and we're
still upset about what happened against
the chiefs and the next thing you know
they're in a meat grinder because and
this is a point that sims made rahim
morris knows the john gruden offense
raheem morris was there
running practices against the john
gruden offense and he knew how to shut
down the john gruden offense and gruden
didn't have an answer for it so i i
don't know that
that it means they definitely don't get
in they've got three games they should
win they've got two games who knows down
the stretch they get the jets this
weekend to get to seven and five
but
it's just the kind of loss
that should disqualify them there should
be some provision in the rule book that
if you get beaten that badly after
thanksgiving by a losing team you just
get removed from cut it out florio cut
it out florio because i don't care we've
all been we've all been part of great
teams and we've all had those type of
disappointing losses the key and most
important thing here is how carr comes
back his job is to take care of the
football and be a fishing coach and that
that's something that we we hadn't we
weren't really used to seeing him turn
the ball over this year
hey rodney i agree with you sometimes
that sometimes that loss comes in the
super bowl after you're 18-0 so i'll
agree with you
very true very true no but here's the
key i feel it in my side good job
what kind of personality do you have
what is the character of that team 2006
december
i meant with the indianapolis coast we
lost the game 41-17 gave up almost 400
yards rushing six weeks later we're in
the super bowl um
you know the raiders that was a bad game
but what kind of team do they really
have are they going to be able to bounce
back and pull it together that's what
we've got to see
you keep in mind something from last
year with the raiders this was a team
that was six in four in late november
they won three straight games then they
finish up losing five of their final
sixth and they finished seven and nine
that's a tough dig there florio on
rodney now i feel like i feel like i'm
on rodney's side now and you're the bad
guy
the tables have turned here and i'm
excited about
it to this don't worry liam don't worry
about it i'm being very humble right now
but when i see him i'm gonna put my
hands around his throat
he'll forget he will be it won't be till
next september he'll forget
the earliest he'll be virtual from west
virginia now for years to come simply
because of what happened here today
all right we move on cleveland browns
eight wins eight and three most wins
since the bill belichick days is the
browns team hasn't been to the playoffs
since 2002 hasn't won a playoff game
since resuming operations in 1999. you
think about bad losses i mean they lost
16 to six to vegas they got crushed by
pittsburgh crushed by baltimore but that
was week one so rodney you look at the
browns great story one of the good
stories here in 2020 but how seriously
should we take them
i think you have to respect him i think
you know when you watch baker mayfield
he seems like he's playing with a lot of
confidence you know and they're gonna
have to ride those running backs right
into the playoffs they're gonna get
miles garrett back he's gonna be healthy
so that should provide the defense with
a spark but one guy that i'm looking at
that they paid a ton of money to mike
florio and coach is austin hooper this
guy they paid 10 11 million a year for
and they're not even really utilizing
him he's a really good tight end he can
you know open up things especially with
the loss of obj jarvis landry is playing
extremely well but get the ball a little
bit more to austin hooper i think he can
help the offense
and i i've been on the cleveland browns
bandwagon rodney's been ripping me about
that my son justin loves them he tells
me every week watch the browns watch the
browns but you still have to go back to
this they've played four teams with
winning records and the only team liam
gave gave us the three losses they beat
indianapolis so they've got to show us
that they can do it against good teams
they look very good against the weaker
teams baker mayfield has been in control
the defense has been outstanding but
they haven't done it against the good
teams that's what we've got to see
it really is amazing to see how they
fattened up their record against teams
they should beat other than the colts
that was the one that was kind of
questionable now it gets even more
questionable this weekend with the
titans followed up by the ravens we're
gonna learn a lot about the browns they
could be eight and five after these next
two games if they go somehow to ten and
three then they're for real because the
thing is when they get to the playoffs
there's not going to be any of these
easier teams they're all going to be
very difficult teams they have to show
that they can win a game that they
shouldn't win before more people will
take them seriously
but you mentioned if they get to 10 wins
but you would think that they will get
the 10 wins i know that they have the
titans and they have the ravens and
you're right this feel like show me
games right show me that you can beat a
team that you're not supposed to beat
but then it's at the giants and at the
jets back-to-back weeks now they finish
up with the steelers and that's a game
that should matter for pittsburgh so
it's a tough one
but it's giants and jets the 10 wins are
sitting there you guys believe they're
getting in
oh i think they're going to get in but
the question is are you a playoff worthy
team and what are you going to do when
you get there that's the question
and a big and another question is what
yeah i'm sorry mike florio i was going
to say the last question is baker
mayfield it's baker mayfield we know
they can run the football we know they
can make some plays on defense when
they're healthy but the bottom line is
you look at sunday baker mayfield missed
a lot of easy passes that he should have
completed so he's still kind of up and
down trying to get that confidence and
and play well consistently
10 and 6 in 2007 did not get them in
this year there's an extra playoff spot
for the first time so they get the
seventh seed and if they have to go to
kansas city or pittsburgh in that wild
card round they're just not they're not
ready they haven't shown us enough to
get us to say they'd be ready to be
competitive in a game like that
yeah i mean really that's the problem if
you are the last team in you're in a bad
spot in that afc you're in bad spot
either way but especially in the afc and
that brings us to the cults right now
because they are 7-4 they are the final
team right now as we speak
in the afc playoff picture which if
things continue to trend in the
direction that they're trending right
now would mean that they would open up
on the road in the postseason in kansas
city against the super bowl champion
chiefs so the colts is the team that
just lost big to tennessee but they've
beaten tennessee they beat green bay
they give up a lot of points the last
couple of weeks mike florio what's your
read right now on the colts
i think the loss on sunday to the titans
is particularly troubling because as
ryan tannehill told me after the game
the colts don't do a lot of exotic
things on defense they're just a
physical team and they got out physical
now they didn't have deforest buckner he
was on the cove at 19 reserve list so
they need him back but
their their formula is very simple go
out and be physical and overpower your
opponent and they should be able to pick
up some wins we already talked raiders
they play the raiders in a couple of
weeks so maybe the winner of that game
gets in and the loser doesn't but
they've got two games against the texans
who have played better they have the
steelers still on the horizon and then
they finished the season with a chance
at revenge against the jaguars who gave
him their first loss of the season so
they just have to get back to their
physical style they have to forget about
this titans game quickly because uh yeah
they're dancing on the line of
potentially being on the outside looking
in
yeah they got and first and foremost
go ahead coach
i i go back you know to my experience
there too we we played some bad
defensive games when we didn't have bob
sanders and you say well one person
shouldn't make that much difference
deforest buckner makes a big difference
in that defense they were missing a
couple of other starters in the front
seven but when they get him back i don't
worry about their defense and they have
shown the ability they've beaten some
good teams to me it all falls on phillip
rivers is he going to play good football
is he going to make those big throws is
he going to not turn the ball over they
can they can beat a green bay they've
showed us they can do that if he plays
well coach i agree with you totally as
far as their defense i don't have too
many concerns when they're healthy
they're missing three key starters on
that defense offensively that's where i
have some concern you mentioned phillip
rivers i look at the wide receivers they
don't have that number one guy ty hilton
he he's hurt all the time he doesn't
practice so you know when you watch him
play he's not the same player that we're
used to seeing he can't create any
separation their tight ends have been
really good for him nahim heinz he's
been their best player on offense but
it's gonna come down to phillip rivers
and i think his lack of mobility and
i've been saying this the last few weeks
i think his lack of mobility is gonna
really be
a big question mark in the playoffs
because it's gonna get cold the
weather's gonna start to change and if
you're not a mobile quarterback where
you can buy some time guys are going to
get jammed at the line of scrimmage guys
are going to come off the line of
scrimmage a little slower because of the
weather i think it's going to
significantly impact the colts offense
liam
yeah i mean they're a fascinating team
mike mentioned it this team that started
off the season with a 27-20 loss to the
jacksonville jaguars they're seven and
four you gotta figure frank wright going
to be in the mix strong consideration
for coach of the year you go back to the
browns and you compare him to the colts
and tony i'll start with you i mean
you'd rather play the browns i would
assume first round of the playoffs in
the colts the cultures seem like a
dangerous team because there is
potential on defense
well well both of those teams have good
defense and they've got difference
makers on defense
the cleveland browns have a great
running attack and you know if you
cannot stop the run you don't want to
see them in a cold weather game late in
the year um so it just i don't know you
almost have to pick your poison colts
have some weaponry on offense uh i think
the colts are a better more well-rounded
team but i wouldn't want to play the
browns in a cold weather game in january
yeah coach it just comes down to
matchups and that's what it comes down
to which team do you match up better
with you know yeah obviously phillip
rivers and his experience and things
like that but i just went through some
of their weaknesses on offense it'd be
good to get jonathan taylor back because
the last couple weeks he's provided them
with some solid running
one of the things i learned from rodney
a long time ago and i have heard her
learned plenty from sitting next to
rodney on sundays even when he isn't
trying to beat me up but uh it all
changes in the playoffs everything gets
more intense everything is faster
everything is higher stakes and it helps
to have guys in the locker room who have
experience so they can make sure that
the players who don't have the
experience understand what's coming the
cults have the experience that would be
a reason that i'd be leery about the
calls i got the force buckner who was in
the super bowl last year philip rivers
has been in the postseason they got guys
who've been on that team for years that
have been in the postseason from time to
time the browns other than jarvis landry
right now you know they got some got
like like an andrew sendejo who was with
kevin stefanski in minnesota and he's
been there and done that but you've got
more guys in indy who have that playoff
experience so that's another reason i
would not want to play the colts
move over to the nfc and you talk about
a team that from the quarterback and the
coaching standpoint certainly lacks that
playoff experience it's the cardinals
now six and five one of the most
entertaining teams in the league
certainly one of the most dramatic teams
in the league but also one of the most
perplexing teams in the league
back-to-back losses they're coming off
of seattle that new england lose to both
those teams they have those early
back-to-back losses against detroit and
carolina
six and five right now the last team in
that nfc playoff picture
tony i'll start with you
i mean they're tough team to get a real
good read on
what do you think the plain and simple
truth is about this team right now
well they're a dangerous team
but you look at as you say who they've
lost to okay losing
to new england losing to carolina losing
to detroit that that shows you that this
is not a team that's there uh they can
play they can get that hail mary that
big play to win a game they can play
great and kyla murray can be outstanding
but they can come back and play a
stinker game against the bad team so uh
i think there's still a little bit of a
roller coaster dangerous team but not
consistent enough to really be a threat
in the playoffs i don't think but but
also coach
it seems like offensively kyla murray
has to be able to run and and have
success running the ball in order for
the offense to have success the last
couple weeks seattle and the patriots
did a great job of sort of corralling
him and you know he's got a you know
he's got to deal with some issues too
because you know he's kind of up and
down and his personality you see him
walk off to the sideline and have you
know some riffs with his teammates they
just need to continue to try to just
play football get some shots down the
field be a lot more efficient on third
down and i think they'll have a chance
but defensively i'm still concerned i
think isaiah simmons they're doing a
good job with him trying to figure out
where they want to put him they put him
at defensive end they put him at
linebacker he was playing some strong
safety when he hit cam newton
inbounds so
i like arizona but i think colin murray
he just carries so much pressure and he
has he has to release some of that
pressure it can't be all on him
i can't help but wonder
whether the hail mary play to beat the
bills stuck with this team more than it
should in a bad way because at the end
of the day they didn't win any trophies
for winning that game but there was an
exuberance there was a euphoria from
that team
that that maybe made them forget you
know hey we got a quick week here and we
got to play the seahawks and we've got
the patriots after that and it feels
like the seahawks cracked the code on
how to shut down kyler murray as a
runner oh he got injured along the way
with the shoulder problem and then the
patriots after not being able to contain
deshaun watson were able to contain
kyler murray and yeah they're now in
danger of not making it and they have a
game against the 49ers still to come and
the 49ers coming up on the outside i i
am concerned that the cardinals are
going to end up losing that seventh spot
to a team like the 49ers in minnesota
because yeah they don't have that
experience being in a spot like this and
they feel like the walls are closing in
and that magic
that magic was all used up in the hail
mary play against the bills and i just
feel like they're having a hard time
getting it back
but also florida when you're a good team
and you win games like that you better
expect other teams to come ready to play
and i think that's what you see you know
people respect the arizona cardinals
before they were one on those teams
where you just mark off yep this is a
win this is a win and now you have to
deal with kylie murray now you have to
deal with some of the different
personalities on that defense and on
that offense so these guys are going to
be competitive they're not just going to
walk away and lay down but it's it's
gonna come down to colin murray and how
he kind of handles himself in these
pressure moments liam
yeah and rodney all the teams they're
facing down the stretch here they're all
gonna come ready to play um six and five
right now this team they have the rams
they're at the giants who are trying to
get in the nfc east the eagles who as
bad as they look are still right in the
mix to win the nfc east and then the
49ers and then at the rams is the way
they finish that up it's the way we'll
finish things up here because the rams
are seven and four they're second in
that nfc west got a couple good wins
they beat the seahawks they beat the
bucks
i don't know if you can call any of
their losses terrible right at buffalo
at the 49ers at miami this past weekend
to the 49ers when you look at this team
right now
it comes down to trust and i know that
they can play defense but can you trust
this rams team as a whole
to go far in the playoffs i don't
because right now i don't trust jared
goff i think jared goff and sean mcvay
and sean said in his post-game
conference he was very frustrated with
jared goff and and just turning the ball
over if they can just focus on running
the football the play-action pass the
boots and things like that and get rid
of those
those turnovers they have a chance but
anytime adversity hits it seems like
jared goff he gets nervous and he falls
back into being turtle for prone so no i
don't trust him at this point in time
coach
well rodney and what you don't trust is
their quarterback jared goff comes out
at tampa and you say my goodness this he
destroyed the buccaneers and you say hey
this might be the best team in football
they've got a great defense they can run
the ball they've got all this weaponry
and if golf plays like that they're
going to be lights out and then the next
two weeks he's turning the ball over and
not hitting open receivers and it's
almost like sean mcvay has to hide him
and and play around him so which
quarterback is going to show up if the
jared goff at tampa shows up they can
beat anybody
there was a very interesting moment
earlier this week when sean mcvay did a
press conference after game day and he
was asked
whether he considered benching goff in
any of the two losses that they've had
recently either in miami or on sunday
against the 49ers and you know coach
peyton manning i'm sure at some point
had a rough name if somebody would have
asked you did you consider benching
peyton manning you would have started
laughing just like you did now no you're
not benching peyton manning yeah and and
and sean mcvay launches into this
three-minute answer explaining in detail
why and it's like wait a minute if this
guy's your franchise quarterback there's
no there's no
answer longer than he's a franchise
quarterback so that really made me think
sean mcveigh's wondering what's up with
jared goff i did call him out as rodney
said after the game for having too many
turnovers and i go to their running game
sean mcvay wants to do the kyle shanahan
thing with all these different guys who
run the football and it's not working
they need to pick a guy that's what the
rams have always been they have a guy
develop a guy and have a backup to that
guy and a back up to that guy but this
revolving door thing just isn't working
they never develop an identity on
offense and if your identity is jared
goff it's not going to carry you to
where you want to go
and mike i think the key points you made
right there not even sean mcvay's answer
but the fact that he got the question if
you're a super bowl caliber team are you
ever getting the question am i benching
my quarterback no you know
no you're not
and the answer should be the shortest
answer in history
right it should just be that's you
should almost just be given you should
be giving the reporter a look like why
would you ask me that there's no way but
listen it's a matter of trust and right
now i don't think jared goff has that
trust we're in the first week in
december guys final day the nfl season
is january the 3rd we're going to see
how many of these teams get in what they
can do in the playoffs but guys as we
finish up it is wednesday that we are
recording this podcast it's a football
wednesday which means there are
traditions it means you start with
football guys and then you know what
comes after football right
it's the tree lighting
[Laughter]
tradition liam i have an important
question is that a ceramic tree
oh yeah you know it
yeah my mother
used to make those she had an assembly
line in the basement she may you may
need to turn that upside down
and see if her initials are on it
because i'm telling you she made
hundreds of those things so that's a
nice memory do it liam no i'm serious
she did no you i don't i doubt that i
doubt that one of her ceramic trees made
its way to to new york state or wherever
it is you grew up where did you grow up
i i knew that at some point was it i
grew up in new york new york yeah
i doubt that her i doubt that her her uh
delivery
radius went quite that far but yeah
that's a nice memory because i'm telling
you i know that tree and those trees
were everywhere when i was growing up
check it out we literally made hundreds
of them we gotta i gotta look all right
what are the initials he's gonna break
it it's mf i am good but we've had this
thing in my family for like it's gonna
be forever he's gonna break it
here it goes what do we got i don't see
initials
i don't see an issue i got nothing here
there are pieces mike you just want the
profit that's all you just want the
profit mike
uh look and now it's tilted and there
are things falling off there you go
man 2020 guys it continues tradition all
right traditions
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports